Hi everybody ! Thank you again for the introduction
I'm Shelley, a software engineer at GitHub
working on open source.
Today, I would like to do a deep dive into
the mechanics of asynchronous programming
in JavaScript.
To make sure we're all on the same page, before
I get started, I will go over basic principles
of asynch, and then we will launch into the
different methodologies and nuances of what
exactly differentiates them, and, finally,
we will compare over the spectrum of options
to discuss which situations require which
approaches.
Let's say you have a programme detained within
a contained within a final file.
It's mate up of functions.
At any given time, only one of these is going
to be executing now.
The rest will execute later at some point
in the future.
That, there, is the crux of asynch.
It's the relationship between now and later,
and the way in which you manage this relationship
with your code.
What is key here, however, and what causes
some of the most difficulties for developers
when they're just starting out, is that later
does not mean strictly and immediately after
now.
It could be at any point in the future, and
you don't necessarily know when that will
be.
Now, let's move on to some of the technical
underpinnings of how code is executed in the
JavaScript environment.
In pursuit of this understanding, it's best
to start with the event loop.
The event loop can best be conceptualised
as an endlessly running singly threaded loop
where each iteration runs a small chunk of
code in the programme.
If you want to run a chunk of code at a later
time, that chunk would simply be added to
the queue for the event loop.
When the time came that you desired it to
execute, it would be dequeued and executed.
With ES6 came a new concept called the microtasks
queue, but we will save that for a little
bit later.
It is also important to mention that JavaScript
has what is known as run-to-completion semantics.
This means that the current task always finishes
before the next task begins.
Or until it explicitly yields control back
to the event loop.
As a result of this, each task has complete
control over all current states, and does
not need to worry about another task modifying
things at the exact same time.
Looking at the code here, running this will
always print first and then second, because
the function, starting in setTimeout is added
to the task queue immediately but only executed
after the current piece of code is down since
it yielded control.
Now let's look at the call stack.
When a function foo calls a function bar,
bar needs to know where inside foo to return
to after it's done.
This information is managed with the call
stack.
Take a look at the set of three functions
on the left-hand side of the slide.
Let's walk through how the stack will look
as the programme executes.
Initially, when the programme above has started,
the call stack is empty.
After foo is called, the stack has one entry:
location and global scope.
As I mentioned before, foo knows where to
return to when it has finished.
Next, after bar is called, the stack has two
entries.
It's now stored at the location that bar needs
to return to when it has finished executing
in addition to global scope.
The trend continues as bas is called, containing
the previous return address and the previous
return addresses from previous calls.
When console.log is called in bas, the call
stack is... the console.
Next, each of the functions terminates, and,
each time, the top entry is removed from the
stack.
After foo is done, we're back in global scope
and the call stack is empty.
At the end, we return, and the programme is
terminated.
In looking at this, you can see a handful
of the things I previously mentioned.
The event loop, the task queue, and the stack.
The current task comes off of the event queue
and its location is stored in memory while
irrelevant variables populate the heap.
The task queue is populated by task sources,
any one of which would be a particular chunk
of code in an executing programme.
This snapshot would represent the moment after
the all functions in the previous slide had
executed and before locations had begun to
pop off of the stack.
Most of you have likely encountered callbacks,
so I'm going to focus more on how they fit
into the asynch landscape as a whole.
Let's start by looking at some functions and
discussing them in context.
Here, you can see I have two programmes side
by side.
On the left, the function names are alphabetical
from top down, and, on the right side, I've
mapped the functions to the order in which
they run.
Most likely, your eyes have to do a significant
amount of jumping around in order to discern
the order in which the functions are executing
for the programme on the left.
Since they're not running in the top-down
sequential order you might expect.
By following the Cardinal number of words
on the right side, you probably had an easier
time.
Let's talk about why that is.
Your brain operates sequentially.
It places it at odds with the inherent functionality
of callbacks.
This is a comparatively simpler example, but
when callbacks start to next significantly,
you enter what is known colloquially as callback
hell which becomes more difficult for your
brain to reason of through.
What is happening here in terms of the call
stack, and, by extension, the event loop?
Assuming all these functions are asynch, first
we will begin, and then immediately yield
control, and, then second, execute.
A callback was registered by first so the
next available task will be that callback.
Next, third will execute, followed by fourth.
Fourth registers a callback, at then returns
control, so that fifth executes.
The callback registered by fourth will come
off the Q and execute, and — the queue and
execute, and finally, six will execute.
For each of these functions taking a callback,
the callback itself is a black box for the
function.
The continuation of the programme is dependent
on our handing that callback off to another
part of the code and then essentially just
praying that it will do the correct thing
whether the callback is invoked.
This paradigm is known as inversion of control,
and can create significant trust issues.
In the previous code snippet I had up, you
could see that your eyes had to skip around,
even though they most likely wanted to read
the code in a top-down fashion.
When you sometimes struggle to understand
how and when each part of a piece of code
is working, it's undoubtedly hard to deal
with errors in that code been within the callback
landscape, there are two ways in which errors
are reported: via callbacks and via exceptions.
You need to combine both properly.
This is because the most obvious, but occasionally
overlooked aspect of dealing with errors in
callbacks, is to make sure that they've actually
all been handled.
However, there's a caveat to this advice,
and it lies specifically in how errors are
caught: can you see how, in the snippet above,
I returned and didn't throw an error.
That is intentional.
In an asynchronous environment, the exception
could be thrown, and, when the lock is out
of scope, the error would be rendered meaningless.
The next big innovation in asynchronous programming
promises hit JavaScript with ES6.
Before this, there was no direct notion of
asynch built directly into the JavaScript
engine.
All it ever did was execute a single chunk
of your programme at any given moment when
asked to.
You, the developer, asked it to by means of
callbacks or timeouts, in order to shuffle
its place in the event loop.
With promises came a change to the JS engine
which took a form of the queue that I mentioned
briefly at the beginning — the microtask
queue.
Before I delve into how exactly this changes
the form of the stack queue event loop diagram
I showed you a few slides ago, let's look
at an example of a programme utilising promises
and then discuss what is happening and why.
Promises act as placeholders.
They allow us to reason about future values
without necessarily knowing their outcomes,
making them functionally extemporaneous.
When the future value is settled, it might
succeed or fail.
Then, at that point, the promise is no longer
a placeholder and becomes an immutable value.
A few slides ago, I referenced the paradigm,
the version of control.
Promises confer to us a capability to know
when a given task finishes.
Promises may seem like an entirely different
paradigm, but they don't get rid of callbacks
at all.
They just change with the callback has passed
to, and remove the black box effect we saw
previously.
We get back from a function when it is completed,
and then perform new passes from there, as
I said.
Promises are not just the mechanism for single-step
operations that follow with this then that
flow.
[Sound distorted].
From the — calls for
the second then would create then another
promise.
So, how does this look under the hood?
Promises utilise the microtask queue by allows
us to say, "Here is this thing that I need
to do later but I need to ensure it happens
immediately later from the — the microtask
queue can best be thought of as attached to
each tech in the event loop.
Some asynch actions will be added to the end
of the current microtask queue instead of
creating a whole new tick as a whole.
When a promise is resolved or rejected, the
associated handlers will be called asynchronously
as microtasks, and then added to the queue
for the current tick.
This diagram looks nearly identical to the
diagram I showed you a few slides back.
One key difference from the microtask queue.
Once a promise settles or already settling,
it queues a microtask.
This ensures promise callbacks are asynch
even if the promise has already settled, so
calling it then would resolve a reject against
the settled promise immediately queues a microtask.
Any additional microtasks queued during a
given microtask are added to the end of the
queue and also processed.
So, in looking at the diagram, you see that
the current task can come off the task queue
or the microtask queue.
All promised callbacks are queued as microtasks.
A microtask can also cause one or more microtasks
to be added to the end of the same queue.
So it's theoretically possible that a microtask
loop could spin indefinitely thus starving
the programme of its ability to move on to
the next event loop tick.
This would conceptually be almost the same
as expressing an infinite loop in your code.
What happens if something goes wrong in a
promise.
How do we deal with those errors?
By default, it turns out, promises are swallowed
if unhandled.
More specifically, any exception which is
thrown inside a dot.then handler, or within
a function path, a new promise will be soundly
disposed of unless manually handled.
The standard way to handle errors from promises
is to add a catch handler at the end of your
promise chain.
You can also chain these handlers so that
you can throw errors into progressively more
outer level scopes.
Catching and rethrowing errors in this way
will tell you what led to the error more effectively
so that you can later debug the issue more
efficiently.
If exceptions are thrown inside the callbacks
of dot then and dot catch, it's not a method
because these two can revert them to rejections.
Let's look at an example and talk about what
would work and what wouldn't in more concrete
terms.
This is a simple promise example.
From looking, you can see that from is going
to reject with an error, no matter what.
So, what happens in the first example versus
the second?
The first has a catch.
So it's going to print the error followed
by the error message which in this case is
rejected.
You can also see the associated call stack
by printing error.stack.
The second one doesn't have a catch.
So even though we threw an error, it will
simply fail silently.
This next type of asynch approach — generators
— sits a little on the edge of the overall
asynch landscape but is nevertheless important
to touch on.
The first thing to observe as we talk about
generators, is how they differ from normal
functions.
There are several notable differences but
key to generators is their behaviour with
respect to the run to completion expectation.
With generators, we have a different kind
of function which can be paused in the middle
either once or several times.
It is resumed later which allows other code
to run during these pause periods between
runs.
The main strength of generators is that they
provide a single threaded synchronous-looking
code style but allow us to hide the asynchrony
away as an implementation detail.
This lets us express naturally what a programme
step and statement flow is without navigating
the asynchronous gotchas and syntax at the
same time.
To get an idea of how this looks in practice,
let's see a function.
Here, you will see immediately that there's
a little star next to the function in the
signature.
This is the syntactical indicator that you're
looking at a generator function.
The key word "yield" will send out a value
whenever the function is run.
So, here, the yield index plus plus expression
will send the index value out when pausing
the generator function at that point.
If ever the generator is restarted, whatever
value it was sent in will be the result of
that expression.
It will then get added to one and assigned
to the index variable.
When we start, index is zero.
So this will be yielded and then 1 will be
added to the index as a result of the plus
plus.
This will occur each time as the value of
index is passed out and then in again, and
so that it increments by one every time.
To see this a little more clearly, let's look
at a diagrammatical representation.
On the left, you will see a traditional non-generator
function.
It adheres to the run to completion behaviour
we expect from functions with no interruptions
from beginning to end.
On the right is the generator function.
With multiple stops and starts between beginning
and end.
It's important to note that there is no real
official end per se in the generator function.
The end in this case will be the last time
that that yield is called.
When the generator function is initialised,
an iterator is returned, and then the generator
starts with the first call to next on the
function.
This function pauses when yield is called,
and then would restart with the next call
to next, and so on, and so forth.
To recap, with normal functions, you get parameters
at the beginning, and a return value at the
end, but generator functions, you send messages
out with yield, and you send messages back
in with each restart.
One of the most powerful parts of ES6 generator
design is that the semantics of the code inside
the generator are synchronous.
Even if the external iteration control proceeds
asynchronously.
That's a fancy way of saying that you can
use a very simple error-handling technique
you're probably familiar with — the tri
catch mechanism.
If even if the function will pause at the
yield expression, the tri catch with catch
it.
With normal asynch capabilities like callbacks,
that's almost impossible to do.
The generator itself has a throw function
to throw an error into the generator at its
pause position which of course can also be
caught by a try catch inside the generator.
Asynch await is a new way to write asynchronous
code.
Previous options are callbacks and promises.
Asynch await was created to simplify the process
of working with and writing chained promises.
And so asynch await functions themselves return
promises.
They cannot be used with plain callbacks.
Asynch await is thus like promises non-blocking,
and makes asynchronous code look and behave
more like synchronous code.
This is where all the power lies.
Since any asynch await function returns a
promise implicitly, the resolve value of the
promise will be whatever you return from the
function to ill straight, let's look at.
Here, we are returning a string that returns
several components of a street address.
The function has the asynch key word before
it and the await key word can only be used
in function s defined with asynch.
All four variables must be resolved before
the function will return the desired string.
Also important to note here is that if we
did not use the await key cord before each
of the address component functions, this would
not necessarily fail.
It would just mean that the variables would
be set to promises and from the values returned
from them.
There is it also an oft overlooked gotcha.
Await calls operate sequentially.
What this means is that the call to get.city
won't kick off until we have a value for get.street
address.
In some, this depends on a call from results
of a previous call.
Here, we want to get the address components
simultaneously, so we should not be blocking
each on the previous one.
Instead, we should rewrite it like this.
Under the hood, asynch await works almost
exactly the same as promises, utilising the
new microtask queue introduced to handle asynch
operations.
If you're familiar with promises, you know
that, if a promise is rejected, you need to
handle that error inside a catch.
If a handle be errors for synchronous and
asynchronous code, you will likely have to
duplicate your error-handler.
In the above snippet, we can see there is
duplicate code on lines 6 and 8.
The catch statement on line 7 will handle
any errors that the synchronous function do
synchronous things may throw, but it won't
handle any errors thrown by do something since
it's asynchronous.
This example may seem palatable, since all
it's doing is printing the error to console,
but if there is any kind of complex error-handle
be logic, we want to avoid duplicating it.
Asynch await let's us do exactly that.
But looking at the code snippet on the top
right, you will see that we only catch once.
When we use asynch await, we can catch errors
in a single handler.
Here, we can both minimise the total amount
of code that we write and catch errors in
a more readable and clear way.
So, wrapping up: our brains plan things out
in sequential blocking singly threaded semantic
ways.
But callbacks express asynchronous flow in
a rather non-linear and non-sequential way.
Which makes reasoning properly about such
code much more difficult.
Callbacks suffer from lack of sequentiality
and lack of trustability, but they're good
in situations where you may just be performing
a simple request that is always asynchronous.
They're just plain functions, so they also
don't require any additional understanding
beyond knowing how asynchronous operations
work.
They also at the end to be more verbose, so
co-ordinating multiple asynchronous requests
with them concurrently can lead to callback
hell if you're not actively modularising your
functions.
Dealing with errors also tends to be more
confusing, since there could be many error
objects that all go back to a single error
further down the call stack.
Promises are easier to reason of about.
Although they still have their downsides.
There are they are especially useful for co-ordinating
multiple asynchronous operations, propagating
errors from nested asynch operations, and
dynamically chaining asynchronous operation
s, i.e., those where you would do something
asynch, examine output, and then do something
else asynch, based on the intermediate values.
Errors and error stacks in promises can also
be a challenge, because they behave unintuitively
in the way that they print errors when those
errors are thrown.
They brought new changes to the JavaScript
engine and paved the way for later innovations
like asynch await.
This latest asynch pattern is basically syntactical
sugar on promises, but it allows for more
intuitive reeled of asynchronous code.
It improves error handling compared to traditional
promises and can be handled with simple try
catch blocks.
It is so easy to use asynch await that one
of its slight dangers that you forget you're
writing asynchronous code at all.
Ultimately, the best tool to use for a job
is going to be the one that is most specific
to the job that you're doing.
Now, I hope you'll have a firmer grasp on
what exactly makes each of these tools a best
fit for certain jobs.
And be able to use them with the deeper understanding
of what is going on at a granular level.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]